the explosive ending of Joaquin
Phoenix's origin story for the Joker
will have fans debating his version of
the iconic comic book villain for years
to come however the original ending was
even more chilling and had a brutal
connection to Heath Ledger's Joker on
top of that over 30 minutes of
additional footage didn't make it into
the final film meaning there are lots of
deleted scenes missing from the
theatrical Curt yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm John and in this video I'm
revealing all the deleted scenes from
2019 Joker and explaining the alternate
ending you never got to see there will
of course be spoilers so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet in the
film we watch arthur fleck pass through
multiple breaking points on the way to
his transformation into the joker one of
these is his discovery of the abuse he
suffered as a three-year-old child but
the original screenplay delved even
deeper into Arthur's troubled childhood
in a scene scrapped from the final film
Arthur revealed to Sophie that as a
child he'd been bullied by other
children who mocked him and nicknamed
him happy because of his affliction by
the time he was 10 years old
Arthur was so sick of it that he took a
razor to his mouth and cut a smile onto
his face telling his bullies you want
happy here how's this for happy the
childhood injury left Arthur with scars
around the corners of his mouth and
brings to mind the stories of how Heath
Ledger's Joker claimed he got his scars
I don't know what got these scars my
father was a drinker and one night he
comes at me with the knife why so
serious he sticks the blade in my mouth
what's perish smile on that face the
original ending Patoka was going to
revisit Arthur's horrific childhood
self-harm in a scene where after the
police car crashes Arthur escapes grabs
a broken piece of glass and uses it to
carve a long smile into the corners of
his mouth again
although Joker's r-rated and obviously
violent it feels like this original
ending would have been even more
shocking and brutal it's possible the
filmmakers or studio considered showing
Arthur inflict this entry on himself too
gruesome to show on screen there is a
nod to this original idea in the final
version the film though when during the
riots Arthur
takes the blood in his mouth caused by
the car crash and paints a bloody
elongated smile onto his face with his
fingers it's also possible the studio
decided they wanted to avoid any
suggestion that this Joker could be
connected with Heath Ledger's version I
stick a razor in my mouth and do this to
myself now I'm always smiling the
filmmakers have stressed multiple times
that the movie is not connected in any
way to the DC EU and the screenplay also
states that the story takes place in its
own universe and has no connection to
any of the DC films have come before it
Arthur spatial scars would have also
made the scene where he meets the young
Bruce Wayne even creepier because
originally young Bruce was going to
stare at the scars around Arthur's mouth
and then reach out to touch them
foreshadowing the future connection
between the two characters you'll
complete the very final scene of Arthur
in Arkham State hospital who's also
going to be quite different originally
his cut smile was going to be all
stitched herb and the scene with the
hospital doctor played out a little
longer
in an earlier script she asked him if he
was keeping up to date with his journal
and if he'd written about his episode
Arthur nodded and said it was how he
remembered it but when the doctor looked
in the book it was full of empty pages
the movie then ended with an orderly
walking Arthur back to his cell while he
danced to the tune of Frank Sinatra's
That's Life in contrast to the
theatrical version in the original
screenplay Arthur doesn't appear to kill
the hospital doctor nor does he seem to
be about to escape from the ward on top
of these changes to the ending there are
numerous deleted scenes from the first
cut of the movie which according to
director Todd Phillips is a solid half
hour longer than the final version there
are some key moments in the trailer such
as these which didn't make it into the
final movie and I'm going to go through
the screenplay and footage from the set
to let you know what these deleted
scenes are Arthur's relationship with
Sophie is imaginary in the final version
of the movie but originally that wasn't
the case in the script and all of Arthur
and Sophie scenes were real and did
actually happen there are also several
additional scenes between Arthur and
Sophie which were deleted from the final
film after Arthur stalks and follows
Sophie to where she works at Gotham
Savings Bank was on set for
of Joaquin Phoenix coming out of the
bank meaning was an additional scene
inside in the screenplay
Arthur went inside the bank and walked
up to Sophie who worked there as a
teller and pretended he wanted to open
an account in this sequence which was
scrapped from the movie Arthur saw
Sophie visibly shudder when an old a
bank manager put his hand on her
shoulder
later when Arthur and Sophie are out
together she tells him she's been fired
after filing a complaint about the
manager harassing her and trying to
sleep with her
and there's another deleted scene in the
trailers where Arthur is carrying his
wand of flowers if he walks along the
corridor of his apartment block he's
wearing his full joke outfit and is on
his way to the Murray Franklin show in
the original screenplay
Arthur leaves the flowers and an
envelope full of money at Sophie's
apartment door together with a note
asking her to watch him on TV this scene
changed in the final film with Arthur
simply exiting his building without
taking anything to Southie there's an
interesting deleted scene after Arthur
is sacked and returns to the talent
agency to collect his things from his
locker after Arthur leaves there's on
set footage of Randall chasing after him
and the two of them arguing then Arthur
taking off Randall's clown nose and
throwing it into the road the original
screenplay explains that during this
cutscene Randall is annoyed that Arthur
mentioned that he'd given him the gun
Randall warns after that the cops are
all over the subway murders and are now
looking for a clown and that they'll
eventually track him down
Arthur denies he had anything to do with
the killings but Randall seems to know
the truth and he goes on to tell Arthur
that a lot of people in the city are
happy about what happened to the wall
street guys Randall also tells his ex
colleague that masks are now being sold
based on Arthur's clown face a cutscene
teased in the trailer shows Arthur
getting thrown out of Wayne Hall after
his run-in with Thomas Wayne the
screenplay describes the scene in more
detail and that Arthur as a performer
knows how to take a fall and plays it up
in front of the protesters for all it's
worth he rolls to his feet with a bit of
panache and the protesters go crazy
cheering and applauding his act with
Arthur taking a deep dramatic bow this
deleted scene together with Randall
scrapped scene definitely play up even
more the sense of how Arthur's actions
are igniting Gotham citizens to rise
up against the rich a really interesting
fantasy subplot that was cut from the
final film involves Arthur's ginger cat
in the original screenplay the cat
appeared to Arthur whenever he was in
his apartment purring or staring at him
and generally observing whatever he was
doing and as Arthur slowly transformed
into the Joker he began talking to the
cat the final scene with the cat happens
just after Arthur kills Randall we see
it sitting on a windowsill
though the script makes a point of
saying that it has no reflection
suggesting that all along the cat was
just another manifestation of Arthur's
delusions and lack of grip on reality at
that moment he lets the cat out of the
window telling it to be free indicating
how Arthur was finally setting himself
free to embrace a personality of the
Joker entirely this imaginary cat could
have been an intriguing subplot that
paralleled Arthur's descent into madness
but instead it looks like in the final
movie the filmmakers took the fantasy
element of the cat and merged it with
soapy storyline instead the scene after
Arthur kills the three Wall Street guys
on the subway was originally quite
different in the original screenplay
Arthur runs into the public bathroom and
ends up trying to shoot himself in the
head before hiding the gun away then
washing the clown makeup up his face in
the final film this scene was completely
changed with Arthur dancing around and
seemingly embracing this side of himself
in fact Arthur's dancing with something
Philips and Phoenix gave more prominence
to in the final version Philip said in a
Q&A that he always thought that Arthur
had music in him and that they added the
dancing to the bathroom scene to show
that the music is fighting to get out
another deleted scene had Arthur
personally going to Thomas Waynes
offices to hand-deliver a letter from
his mother to her former employer this
onset footage of a scene we never saw in
the final film of Joaquin Phoenix
outside an office and running up to
someone with a letter before falling
over in the screenplay
Arthur also goes inside the office and
asks to see Thomas Wayne but the
receptionist refuses and he ends up
getting thrown out of the building by
security guards
after Arthur's mother is taken to
hospital there's a deleted scene in the
screenplay where a doctor and couple of
nurses comped
Arthur and ask him if he's really the
guy from the clip that was played on the
Murray Franklin show when I was a little
boy and told people I was gonna be a
comedian everyone laughed at me well no
one's laughing now you can say that
again
Arthur tries to deny it but the doctor
and nurses are convinced he's the guy
they saw on TV and begin to point out
how unfunny he was and that Murray made
a real fool of him Arthur
ends up really mad and tells him to go
before he strangles all of them with a
stethoscope later after Arthur has
killed his mother there's a deleted
scene from the trailers which shows
Arthur alone outside this looks like the
scene from the screenplay where Arthur
is at his mother's grave in Gotham's
potter's field Cemetery Arthur was the
only person who attended his mother's
funeral and the two detectives tracking
Arthur were also watching him from a
distance at that point one of Joaquin
Phoenix's favorite scenes ended up cut
from the final edit the scene was part
of the rant and monologue that jokah
delivers on the murray Franklin show
just before he shoots the host in the
head in an interview with The Associated
Press Phoenix explained that he
experimented a lot with his performance
how in some scenes he would cry and in
other versions of the same scene he
would make jokes or be angry the actor
claimed that his best take for the rant
Arthur gives on Murray show couldn't be
used because it didn't work when it was
put together with everything else in the
movie
according to Phoenix the version used in
the movie wasn't very good but it worked
best in the context of the entire film
so what did you think of this joker
origin story and are there any deleted
scenes you wish have been included leave
your thoughts about the movie in the
comments below if you want to learn
about more amazing movie deleted scenes
tapleft for the horrific Pennywise
scenes cut from it chapter two or tap
write for another video you're sure to
LIKE and if you enjoyed this alike is
hugely appreciated and why not unleash
your inner movie lover by subscribing to
get more videos like this every week
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers